un centre le performance pour le futur
du golf français voici comment la
fédération française de golf a présenté
son nouveau bijou un bâtiment de 600
mètres carrés sur deux niveaux
construits au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et sera dédiée
à la pratique du haut niveau un projet à
4 millions d'euros imaginé depuis de
nombreuses années les premières ébauches
du centre elles ont été dessinées il ya
plus de dix ans donc c'est vrai qu'entre
temps on a eu la chance d'accueillir la
ryder cup mais que malheureusement
s'avère repousser le projet mais que
depuis maintenant trois ans et bien on a
commencé les travaux de ce centre avec
d'abord la livraison de la zone de
petits jeux ensuite la livraison d'aidé
des salles de cours pour les athlètes et
enfin le plateau de performance et la
base lit sur le modèle du centre
technique national de clairefontaine
pour le football on retrouve un plateau
de 450 m² avec une zone de petit goût de
practice et une salle de préparation
physique des caméras et des capteurs
permettent également une modélisation du
swing les athlètes auront les
équipements nécessaires pour devenir
joueur professionnel
toute cette technologie qui est mis à
disposition de nos athlètes c'est pour
les faire progresser maintenant la
technologie seule ne suffit pas derrière
toute cette technologie il ya des hommes
et des femmes qui la font fonctionner
qui accompagne nos athlètes et il faut
pour qu'on obtienne des résultats que
l'on recherche et bien qui est la
parfaite symbiose entre les deux
l'humain et la technologie et c'est ce
qu'on va s'atteler à faire ces
équipements sont notamment la
disposition de 12 élèves de la 4e à la
terminale ces jeunes joueurs auront la
possibilité de suivre des cours
directement au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines entre deux sessions
de golf sur le site nous on a créé une
école qui est complètement adapté au
calendrier scolaire non quand il ya des
stages ou des compétitions il y'a pus
écoles et puis sur les sur le temps où
c'est possible on met l'école ce qui
nous permet
dans des conditions incroyables parce
qu'ils ont cours à 2 3 4 maximum donc
ils vont très vite c'est très
personnalisé et ça permet d'avoir les
résultats très intéressants la fois son
point scolarité et de libérer du temps
pour l'entraînement avec ses
installations la fédération française de
golf espère désormais pouvoir faire
entrer des joueurs dans le top 20
mondial dans les prochaines années